ما تزال تطورات قضيه اللاعب اشرف حكيمي
تتكشف يوما بعد يوم وفي جديد القضيه اشرف
يقول خدعوني وقضيه الاغتصاب مدبره هذا ما
كشفه صديق النجم المغربي وجاره في الحي
الذي نشا فيه مؤكدا ان النجم تعرض للخداع
وان اسره اللاعب كلها تعاني بسبب ذلك قضيه
النجم المغربي بدات قبل ايام حين اعلن
القضاء الفرنسي فتح التحقيق رسميا باتهام
حكيمه باختصاب فتاه في باريس فيما اكدت
محاميه اللاعب ان الاتهامات باطله محاميه
نجم باريس سان جيرمان موكلها هادئ ومستعد
التعاون مع السلطات لاجل اظهار الحقيقه
وابعاد الشبهات عنه في هذه التهمه الكبيره
في وقت يؤكد جيرانه ثقتهم ببراءته
البدايات لاشرف حكيمي الى يومنا هذا
نبداها معكم في منطقه غيتافي الاسبانيه
ولد النجم المغربي لاب وامن مغربيين
مهاجرين اسره فقيره تعتني بابنها الذي
يريد ان يصبح لاعب كره قدم رغم كل الشعاب
الفقر لم يمنع حكيمي من هوايته التي دعمها
والداه ليصبح محترفا الاب والام ساهم في
بناء لاعب المستقبل بتجهيزه بكل ما يحتاجه
من اطقم واحذيه وغيرها البدايات دائما ما
تكون صعبه ولكن كان اللاعب ملفتا للنظر
لدرجه ان كشافيري ريال مدريد اختاروه
ليمثل فريق الصغار لديهم ليكبر محققا معهم
دوري ابطال اوروبا وبين نوادي سابقه وانتر
ميلان ثم باريس سان جيرمان مع نجم اشرف
الذي كبر ليبدا حياته العاطفيه في سنه
بالارتباط بالاسبانيه لوسيه لينفصل عنها
ويتزوج بعد ذلك بالممثله هبه عبوك التي
تكبره باثني عشر عاما خمسه عوامل عاشها مع
العب بوك ومع نهايه كاس العالم بدات
شائعات تلاقيهما التي زادت مع تهمه
الاغتصاب التي تلاحق حكيمي في هذه الايام
[موسيقى]
ان السيد حكيمي
اتهم ووجهت له من قبل قاضي تهمه الاغتصاب
السيده ميناج اليوم نريد ان نفهم اكثر
تفاصيل يعني حول قضيه اللعب اشرف حكيمي
التي طرات في هذه الايام لماذا يقول
مقربون بان حكيمه تم خداعه وان مساله
الاغتصاب كانت مدبره كيف
للاسف انا لا استطيع ان ارد على ذلك فهو
فهو موضوع تحت السريه القضائيه ليس هناك
اي امكانيه لتسرب اي معلومات من قبل
الامكان من القضاء او من الشرطه لكن هناك
معلومات في الصحافه حول عدد من المعلومات
حول هذه القضيه وما اقوله عبر الصحافه
وعبر المصادر المختلفه هناك المعلومه
الاول وهو ان هناك سيده اتت الى مركز
الشرطه ليس لتقديم شكوى ضد حكيمي ولكن
للاعلان عن تعرضها للاغتصاب وعلينا ان
نعرف بانه في القانون
الفرنسي ليس هناك ضروره او اجبار للتقدم
بدعوى ضد شخص ولكن انا اعلان عن الجريمه
اعلان اعلام السلطات امر مهم جدا ان نقول
للسلطات بان شيئا ما خطا حصل وليس هناك
ضروره لتقديم دعوى شخص فاذا هذه السيده
لتعلن عن تعرضها للاغتصاب ولكن ليس لتقديم
دعوه ضد حكيمي ولكن هذا كافن لكي تتحرك
الشرطه والسلطات
والمدعي العام للجمهوريه تقدم وقام
بالتحقيق وكلف قد تحقيق بان يكون هناك
تحقيق
لمواجهه اشرف حكيمي ولمتابعته ملاحقته
ونحن في اطار قضيه جرميه جزائيه وهناك
بحسب القانون مهلك 18 شهرا اعطيت لقاضي
التحقيق للاستماع الى السيد حكيمي ولكن
للسيده المتقدمه بالشكوى او بالاخبار ولكن
ايضا الاستماع
للشهود
للخبراء الخبراء الذين سيقدمون نظرتهم لما
حصل لها جسديا ونفسيا ولكن هناك ايضا بانه
وهذه معلومات متداوله في الشرطه هو انها
اتت الى حكيمي سياره تاكسي او اوبر
وبالتالي يجب الوصول الى هذا السائق وان
نعرف فعلا ماذا حصل في الليله هناك الكثير
من المعطيات التي يجب ان يتم التحقيق بها
وامل بان يتم ان تسمح كل هذه الامور لقد
التحقيق بالوصول الى معطيات واضحه
ماذا كان هناك فعلا كما يقول
السيد حكيمي خدعه ام ان هناك جريمه او شيء
ما حصل وماذا كان ذلك الشيء يعاقب بموجب
القانون ام ان اذا كانت هذه العلاقه
هل فعلا الشابه التي وجه تهمه الاغتصاب
لاشرف حكيمي رفضت اجراء اي فحص طبي او
نفسي
ليس هناك بالحقيقه جواب لذلك هذه معلومه
متداوله ولكن السريه القضيه
تغطي هذه المعلومات وانا ليس لدي تاكيد
لهذه المعلومات طيب
نريد ان نفهم ايضا فيما يتعلق بالقانون
الفرنسي كيف يعرف الاغتصاب هل للاغتصاب هو
اخصاب رجل على اقامه علاقه جنسيه مع امراه
ام يمكن تعريف الاغتصاب بمسميات اخرى في
فرنسا يعني فقط لا الامر متعلق بعلاقه
جنسيه مثلا
الفقره القضائيه التي تحدث او القانونيه
التي تحدث تتحدث عن الاغتصاب واضحه
الاختصاب هو كل عمليه جنسيه كامله
بالاكراه بالعنف
بالمفاجاه
وبالتالي هناك مفهوم
التوافق ليس هناك اول القبول وبالتالي ان
الوضع واضح جدا ان الموافقه من قبل الضحيه
على هذه العمليه يجعل بان هناك ليس هناك
اختصار وبالتالي ليس هناك تركيز على ما
قال ما فعلت الضحيه تركيز
التعريف للاغتصاب يرتكز فقط على ما قام به
المعتدي قد يكون هناك
اغتصاب كامل في اي شكل من الاشكال وهناك
اي نوع من الاغتصاب الجنسي ولكن انتهاك
اوهتك لجسد المراه بشكل حسي باي شكل من
الاشكال
بالمفاجاه بالاكراه او بالعنف اذا هذه هي
العوامل التي تحدد ان هناك
اشرب حكيمي هل هو مخول بمغادره الاراضي
الفرنسيه هو تحت الرقابه القضائيه ماذا
بعد ذلك
انها السيد حكيمي وضع تحت مراقبه قضائيه
وبالتالي ان العداله او القضاء تطلب من
السيد حكيمي بان يعلن عن مكان تواجده
ولكنها حر تماما بالتحرك وبالذهاب الى حيث
يشاء ان القضاء يراقب هناك عدد من
المواضيع او الاجراءات المفروضه على السيد
حكيمي ولكن الاهم هو لا يكون هناك علاقه
او تواجد لحكيمي مع هذه السيده ولكن ليس
هناك قرار من القانون او من من القاضي
التحقيق بان يغادر او ان يبقى في فرنسا هو
حر بالتحرك بما لا يؤثر على
حياته المهنيه يستطيع السيد حكيمي ان
يتابع حياته المهنيه بشكل كامل عمله
الرياضي وان يغادر او يعود او يعمل ما
يريد
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المداخله من باريس
المحاميه ماريون ميناج